late night was lit Nicki Minaj made
Stephen Colbert blush while ariana
grande slay Slean Dion but today we got
a rare glimpse of Beyonce's babies guys
the claws are out today between Nicki
Minaj and ex Safari Samuels and it's all
playing out like an episode of Maury on
Twitter the heated back-and-forth start
brewing after Nicki dropped some
bombshells about her history with Safari
during an interview with Funkmaster Flex
on hot 97 everybody on the inside of the
industry knows that I write my lyrics
and knows that I that I put so much
weight on women writing and then for one
person to do something like this to me
out of Cher weakness and passive
aggression and just hatefulness and
vindictiveness I don't because you
because you got caught on a person I was
taking care of you for years and years
because you got caught on a person who
was taking care of you while you're
paying for prostitutes and doing all
sides and stealing their credit cards
and doing well types of dumb oh yes the
former couple broke up in 2014 but it
sounds like these wounds cut deep
because that's when Safari tweeted
remember the night you cut me and I
almost died the police and ambulance had
to take me out the crib on a stretcher
and I had to lie and tell them I was
trying to kill myself so they wouldn't
take you to jail when things like that
start happening more than once it's time
to dip well Nicki fired back you stole
my card and told me he thought it was an
account with free money that I didn't
know about on God God will strike you
down and more for lying ha stop saying
you packed and left on Jesus you came to
my house crying begging to go with me to
Europe to the EMAs I said no dummy
and that was just a taste of their
heated claims among the most savage of
Nicki's Klatt facts was her admitting
she never should have paid to fix his
hairline and quote God don't like ugly
you guys can head over to eat Chelle
9.com to see that hot mess back and
forth I don't know what to believe
alright but Nicki says she's switching
back to the positive stuff about her new
album Queen so I'm gonna do the same the
rapper hit the Late Show with Stephen
Colbert to promote the new
and not even sensors could keep Nicky
was spitting some game to her favorite
late-night host with this flirty version
of Barbie dreams I might Steven after
the show he's gonna come back to work
with a magical glow but
[Applause]
are we still broadcasting I wasn't done
Steven oh and then the ending says but
when you see us please don't stare just
address me as Queen Nikki Colbert
come through Queen Nikki Colbert this is
gold I've literally been dying over this
all day you guys and if that wasn't
enough late-night goodness
Nikki's pal ariana grande surprise The
Late Late Show audience with this epic
Titanic tribute with James Corden it's
one take 13 cover songs and five minutes
and this closer
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm the king of the world oh thank you
Rick my Jack loved you right that's just
the tip of the iceberg folks cuz
tomorrow is her carpool karaoke where
Corden will belt out the Ariana lyrics
he just memorized and we'll find out how
Grande's left hand yes the one with that
$93,000 engagement ring from Pete
Davidson wounded up bandaged
but we're switching gears now to Beyonce
she recently covered Vogue September
issue and it was apparently take your
kids to work day for the mom of three
vogue shared a behind-the-scenes video
of the shoot with photographer Tyler
Mitchell and not only did the hive get
to see cream be let loose like never
before we also got a rare glimpse of the
Carter kids blue roomie answer who are
all on the set I'm gonna zoom in for you
guys okay that might be the tightest
close-up in cinematic history but as we
learned from a source close to Beyonce
and jay-z the proud parents want to show
their kids under their own terms in when
they feel like it but can't you tell the
siblings have a lot of love for each
other all right guys tonight is the
first night of live shows for America's
Got Talent
I'll be on the carpet with the first
batch of contestants as well as judges
Simon Heidi Nell Howie and host Tyra
Banks so I'll have that for you tomorrow
in the meantime be sure to take a look
back at our favorite auditions from this
season all right bye you guys